alors les audiences et bien écoutez sur
les travaux dans la bien très bien
fonctionné en plus 3 millions de
téléspectateurs c'est quand même si
quand même pas mal sans très content
marine très très content presque ça a
été presque une surprise même joie je
l'a appris ce matin ils sont très très
très très content très content très beau
score surtout avec koh lanta en face qui
quand même fait aussi de jolis scores
16% dont même quasiment mais alors mois
la perception que j'ai du contraire
c'est que c'est pas la même que ceux qui
l'ont vu à la télé parce que moi j'étais
dans la salle donc et d'après ce que
j'ai entendu on parlait de problèmes de
son et tout ça ils nous on n'a pas eu ça
dans la salle alors on va revenir
justement sur sur sept soit dans cette
soirée ça a commencé par 21h voici le
lancement auquel on a pu assister
c'était hier sur france 2
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au besoin
[Musique]
je te promets le miel
hamama
ira
[Musique]
nous jetons
qui secret
je ne peux pas
ça
ce teaser
[Musique]
mais
la chanson préférée de laetitia et elle
s'était confiée en début d'émission à
michel drucker regardez de toutes les
chansons de johnny quelle est celle
que vous avez dans le coeur pour
toujours
il y en a beaucoup je te promets je te
promets qui me transporte avec qui le
faire encore pleurer
texte pour voir j'étais pas champion
mais on va le parler
je te promets de sièges aux baisers de
ma bouche je te promets de miel à ma
main qui te touche je te promets le ciel
au dessus de ta couche des fleurs et des
dentelles pour que tes me soit merci
beaucoup et bien s'en servent
mais j'aime bien il a fait le début
d'émission c'était un plateau d'à peine
trois minutes ce moment et elle s'était
imposée non chaîne on vous a pas dérangé
c'est un moment où moi j'ai été comme
pendant tout le concert submergé par
l'émotion
mais ça vraiment alors voilà franchement
on assiste à des achats devraient tous
ceux qui diront mais les démolir parce
que là franchement
visuels de l'émotion bertignac bruel qui
n'arrivait même plus à chanter parce que
l'on a été ému son micro marchait pas
panique il réconfort mais quelle
formidable moment d'émotion et drucker
au début que ce n'était pas du tout
gênant nous sommes dans ce que vous
n'avez jamais eu le talent d'un ami
[Applaudissements]
morizet
vous dire l'objet télévisuel il y avait
des moyens considérables oui on était à
bercy c'était visuellement très réussi
maintenant je vous dis moi je me je vous
dise qu'on a pu lire de gauche et de
droite s'étaient globalement largement
critiquée après c'était très bien cette
bête de belle facture ça il ya eu des
moments compliqués dans le dans le dans
le concert hommage à madame mademoiselle
alors dans l'est pour le visuel
notamment les partis avec johnny qu'on
l'aimé ou pas il y avait la promesse
pour les femmes c'est quand même dur que
c'était fait au départ s'il y avait
cette espèce de lumière qui était équipé
honnêtement très bien j'ai aimé aussi
certaines prestations panier qui chante
plus pénitencier il est parfaitement à
sa place dans son rôle avec ma et à
l'harmonica ça c'était pour moi le
meilleur moment de toute la soirée et
d'un voile à la cantèle le balayage de
lumière c'est bien et dans l'est - il y
avait
elle est beaucoup trop gros plan sur la
spéciale je trouve tout comme voilà trop
de trop c'est trop et je suis d'accord
avec vous moi j'ai trouvé le début
gênant merci madame monsieur g truc
c'est une très belle soirée très bien
produit très belle programmation michel
drucker c'était le bon animateur pour le
faire ça faisait plaisir de revoir une
salle de concert rempli avec dix mille
personnes sachant j'ai trouvé ça très
bien justement je vais pas dix ans j'ai
dit une bêtise hier en fait c'était un
chiffre à un instant t voilà dans ces
deux mille tickets vendus 2008 cinq sens
et donc c'était plein voilà et ceux qui
tapent sur le concert à mon avis c'est
pas pour le show en lui-même c'est plus
pour taper gratuitement sur laëtitia qui
était mise en avant pendant cette soirée
et j'ai trouvé que c'était très bien pas
produit d'ailleurs ça a cartonné en
audience vous l'avez dit ils ont fait
très mal à tf1 c'est aussi pour ça que
koh lanta était plus bas hier soir alors
c'est
du prix des billets il y avait trois
catégories à une catégorie à 84 euros 50
une à 76 euros cinquante et une
troisième à 44 euros 50 hae place a fait
un truc à 50 centimes et un euro cher
qu'une chose c'est qu'il ya eu en plus
de 7000 places vendues il ya eu 700
invités mais ils ont fait un truc très
bien à la fin parce que moi j'étais dans
les couloirs ils sont allés chercher
tout un tas de bikers dehors qui
n'avaient pas les chasser bien et qui
espérait au moins entendre un peu ils
ont fait rentrer à la fin et ça je
trouve ça magnifique mais quand je n'y
étais vivant les places étaient
peut-être si elle était si ce n'est pas
forcément punir
pour un spectacle les passes trouve ça
très cher alors la recette globale se
serait 556 1750 euros alors la question
et c'est un peu la question qui a fait
polémique avant le concert est ce qu'on
sait soit quoi cette somme a servi une
association contre le cancer a
intégralement intégralement personne ne
gagne de l'argent là-dedans ça pendant
le dire france de notre important de le
dire il avait été promis c'est elle et
c'était le cas d'autres artistes ont eu
peur effectivement qu'est ce qu'il est
il allait partir ou ce fric ben voilà
c'est dans l'association il c'est clair
et net c'est vrai alors moi je vous dire
j'étais dans la salle il y avait
beaucoup d'émotion moi moi j'étais très
touché par la ferveur de il a un public
extraordinaire johnny vraiment les fans
étaient là c'était magnifique moi
j'étais très très ému à chaque fois ça
applaudit cei se lever il y avait une
vraie joie et le fait de se retrouver
tous ensemble moi je reconnus plein de
monde aussi d'ailleurs laetitia a
reconnu aussi pleinement de la voyant
passer un peu plein de gens c'était très
émouvant s'était alors je tombe vous
vous parliez du du plateau savais qu'il
y avait beaucoup de stars même si
certaines stars avaient été annoncés et
n'étaient pas présentes on vous dira
pourquoi après
j'ai pas toujours trouver des roms
pour persévérer d'enfants ensemble en
main d'oeuvre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec je vois ce sens oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est vrai qu'il y avait des gens
qui n'étaient pas là y'avait pas eddy
mitchell et pas thomas dutronc il ya
passé julien doré qui était annoncé
qu'il avait juré qui était annoncé
qu'ils n'étaient pas là il est vrai que
la vie des videmment vide évidemment
qu'il devait on lui avait proposé de
chanter 100% bon il n'a pas voulu le
faire on peut aussi le comprendre c'est
dans qu'amir qu'il a chanté à sa place
là on a senti une petite déception à la
fois chez les fans mais aussi de
l'enthousiaste parce que c'est une très
belle chanson et que du coup il a
rattrapé tout le monde admire mais
slimane vos d'avenir c'est la prestation
de slimane qui a été très critiquée j'ai
vu sur le réseau seaman ça faisait
quatre jours qui répétait il avait
carrément perdu sa voix tellement il
avait donné vous savez j'ai reçu florent
pagny aujourd'hui la radio et il disait
il faut balancer quoi quand tu fais du
johnny fait pas n'importe quoi il faut
aller très haut très fort donné toute sa
puissance tous les artistes ont donné
leur puissance ils ont beaucoup répéter
et du coup il n'avait plus de voix et il
démarre sa tournée aujourd'hui il y
avait des ingrédients qui des chanteurs
qui vous et ballack et interpréter les
titres assez classiquement il ya eu un
moment je trouve de grâce où il ya eu
s'est passée cette màj que c'est quand
catherine large et à jarry gabriel est
ce que ça voilà c'est de
l'interprétation
est d'ailleurs mise jallet décrochèrent
évidemment quand on était devant et elle
a vraiment retourné bercy et ça c'est
quelque chose oui regarde
[Musique]
non
à celle qui tombe à plat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bisous
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
oui oui bon puisque john y est unique et
que sa voix est
irremplaçable et inimitable bien qu'il
ait mis très bien c'est oui oui mais
quelques 400 bochenko elle a été
formidable parce qu'elle a vraiment
interpréter il yad'autres en personne
les titres ont été mal donné par
certains chanteurs ils ont voulu faire
du johnny à tel point qu'ils se sont
tous cassé la voix est quasi totalement
il s'était alors il ya eu des moments un
peu compliqué pour certains artistes
notamment patrick bruel qui a commencé
je crois que le pays avait il y avait un
problème de micro ou de paroles on sait
pas bien pour le meilleur et on va
regarder ce moment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes un fan de base
c'était pas ce moment-là dont je parlais
c'était tout début du concert
vie pour le meilleur l'ouverture avec
pas ni d'ailleurs et fiorino ray et
effectivement ils ont raté une strophe
enfin patrick tu es simplement te dirait
du coup c'est l'art angoissé mais alors
totalement il était effondré dans sa
loge et du coup ça n'a eu à un peu gâché
les trois
mois d'abord j'ai bien aimé que michel
rocard soit là au début puisqu'on se
souvient l'émotion qui a eu quand il
fait il pour le décès de johnny hallyday
donc c'était un compagnon de route de
johnny donc totalement légitime que
drucker à michel drucker soit là et
j'étais super content qu'il soit là sur
le concert on s'est bien rendu compte
que c'est pas n'importe qui qui peut
chanter johnny au niveau de l'énergie
catherine ringer c'est pas au niveau de
la voix c'est pas c'est pas johnny mais
l'énergie qu'elle mais elle représente
johnny et fiori bruel et panis et les
trois qui ont la voix pour faire du
décès les trois qui ont pu sonder les
trois qu'on la voit pour le faire que ce
soit bruel dit montrait au panier on
connaît et fiori pareil sinon tous les
autres ça a voulu chanter du johnny mais
c'est pas johnny alors c'est pas ce
qu'on leur demandait de nous avoir
demandé d'interpréter geda quiz était là
pour une baignoire et notamment
l'association contre le cancer et
c'était franchement c'est tout
ils ont récolté cinq cent mille france 2
a donné six cent mille pour que ça
existe on donne directement les 600000
au cancer moi je
joue bien je vais bien
je suis contre ces trucs là tous les
quatre on a fêté koala les quatre en
quatre heures après on fait moins quatre
ans et deux semaines non cadres
restant
sur le sujet réellement la production et
c'est vrai qu'on avait en avant on avait
envie de faire croire que donner des là
c'est très compliqué je vous la corde il
était là c'en était là j'ai un gros bac
c'est que c'est vrai que les images qui
était mis dans l'écran nous chez nous on
avait en fait ont filmé la scène et
l'écran j'aurais bien aimé voir les
images chez moi c'est une petite
remarque voilà entre producteurs venus
sage alors techniquement c'est à la
hauteur oui merci madame autre moment
fort et c'est un paradoxe parce que
c'est un monde qui m'a plu énormément
c'est quand les musiciens on fait fait
la musique de allumer le feu notamment
le progrès est un choix splendide et y
avait pas de chanteurs etc la salle qui
a chanté c'est l'un des jeunes allemands
parce que voilà ça cette jeunesse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d'ailleurs il y avait ni eau respawn et
zazie qui sont les créateurs d'être
vraiment le meilleur d'accord du concert
parce que ça représente véritablement la
liesse des fans de la libé le moment où
sic était assez émouvant c'était le
premier l'ouverture du concert où on
l'entend on entend la voix de johnny sur
je te promets que ça c'était très beau
après franchement pour moi c'était un
massacre 2 à
0 sauf pagny nuage - café une région
hautement très douce et j'aimais
beaucoup ce cas là le joselois
s'ils ont des carrières de ouf et
touchante même sur une soirée non mais
j'ai pas dit qu'il chantait mal sur une
saga de jk moment donné sur du johnny
hallyday c'est compliqué il y avait
peut-être un problème aussi sur la
production moi j'ai trouvé que sa banque
un pour moi je me suis demandé s'il
avait répété des mecs sains ouais ces
débats là
juste à ça je l'avais décision la
production là bas je vois c'est bon
ils sont cela fait 20 ans qu'ils font
des restos du coeur alors on peut tout
dire après le spectacle musical saveur a
priori ça faire après ah non mais après
que le contenu musical vous et vous
écarter les oreilles parfois c'était moi
c'était border on va pas se mentir mais
dans la production elle-même c'était un
vrai spectacle
c'est bien d'aller y avait quand même
des petits moments de flottement de
temps en temps entre les les méprise
d'hépatite b partageait les champs
présentation c'était très bien c'était
perdre et c'était discret chacun est à
sa place à un autre cadet magnifique il
y avait une vingtaine d'artistes qui
étaient là pour la bonne cause
franchement je vois pas pourquoi on
critique ce cancer qui était juste
magique et qu'on ne voit pas
régulièrement à la télévision sa maman
regardez ces images qui vont coûter le
propos justement
[Musique]
là bas tout le monde
ça sort nous aimerions faire quelques
chansons pour vous donc si vous fermez
vos yeux je sois je vais vous invite les
ché
quelque chose du mama
qu'est ce qu'elle a ma gueule
les appareils
il faut quand même il faut souligner le
talent d'yvan cassar qui est le grand
homme dont il n'était rentré avec
appareillé à une usine italia rôle
poupaud directeur artistique la soirée
alors qu'istres magnifique a
parfaitement bien interpréter toutes les
musiques faut les tenir
il était très bien incroyable étaient
inquiets chantait le hms york mais pas
d'idées alors qu'elle merad j'avoue
avoir été bluffé il a chanté comme un
chien
une fan de base qui vont intervenir
parce qu'il n'a pas bien compris que
gilles labbé avait vraiment adoré ce
programme sophie des raisons totalement
c'est à dire des choses comme ça sans
réagir on a un spectacle familial un
immense concert gratuit à 1h30 en écoute
gratuite par europolitique
l objet télévisuel director et laissez
moi faire donc
on peut pas dire ça immense une émotion
un moment de partage de toute la france
et vous vous permettez de critiquer
excusez moi mais qui êtes vous prêts
ville sais pas si vous avez l'intention
des réseaux hier soir c'était très
largement défavorable pendant alors
calmement et dans la politesse le
respect en 5 j louis kiehl ça moi je
suis une très grande fan de johnny
hallyday où j'ai eu la chance m'a
rarement la chance de le voir sur scène
mais là et tu as les frais sont pas les
trucs quand ils arrivent quand il envoie
l'envi d'avoir envie que ces élus là ça
envoie les héros c'était pour moi c'est
zéro alors oui c'est un grand moment
c'est sympa c'est familial on est
content parce que c'est johnny et
johnnie la forme tout le monde et tout
le monde aime mes excuses moi pour moi
c'était ça la hauteur de dieu c'est bien
vous êtes excusé c'est correct
vous souhaitez c'est vrai que c est ce
que ça aurait pas été mieux de nous
repasser de ce concept incroyable à la
tradition non mais vous avez raison mais
j'ai le fond mais là c'était très
sympathique les chanteurs avec lesquels
d'ailleurs la touche il a chanté avec
tout le monde toutes ces tares éloignant
duo l'a fait des duos avec toutes ces
filles avec qui avec loane non si la
génisse faire avec nolwenn il a chanté
avec tout le monde avec calogero même
travailler ensemble non c'était
magnifique c'était un très grand roman
et que de belles émotions mois de façon
rien que dans le temps johnny et les
chansons de johnny et elle adore va pas
se plaindre tout le temps qu'ils
priaient qu'il soit fait et quand il a
appris
tout ce qui est important ce moi j'suis
nostalgie de la télé d'avant août où les
stars elles venaient pour filer à
l'étude et je vais
carpentier tout ça mais le monde venait
pour fou pour jouer pour s'amuser voilà
y'a par les restos n'y a pas de
programme comme à la télé je le regrette
parce que matt reeves sont tous tort
comme sur les réseaux ils viennent plus
à la télé fait [ __ ] le bordel et jouer
on sent 23h15 c'était la fin du concert
regardez c'était très beau
les planteurs
m
[Musique]
l'état
b
et toi
[Musique]
alors j'étais un bel hommage et
l'importante et de renommage administrés
quand on entend chanter est ce qu'on
appelle les poils qui se dressent serait
que derrière c'est compliqué c'est
difficile
démarre le spectacle je te promets de
goldman qui était magnifique c'était
johnny tout seul et là il termine avec
la quête qui est une chanson
merveilleuse tir et nicolas mas l'homme
de la mancha c'est magnifique c'était
magnifique moi j'ai passé une très belle
soirée et très émouvante et bravo à dmls
tv et là deux marques a su kaka produit
ça attaquait
alors aujourd'hui forcé boyer beaucoup
de beaucoup de réactions et notamment
laurent ruquier dans son émission des
grosses têtes sur rtl oui voilà qui a
rebondi sur l'émission et qui a fait de
laurent ruquier dans le texte à regarder
laeticia hallyday s'est bien rendue sur
la tombe de johnny pour lui présenter
son nouveau fiancé thani l'espère à
l'utiliser regarde comment tu vas finir
[Musique]
ils ont baisé sur la tombe non mais
stérile qui l'a mis dans le trou
alors forcément me tombe d'un box tv
week end travailler avec lui dans la
course tête ben oui bah qu'est ce que
vous lisez comment faire quelque chose
de rose j'ai connu géniale idée très
tard j'ai jamais vu un concert de johnny
hallyday j'avoue que c'était pas mon
chanteur préféré la certaine j'ai vu des
j'ai vu des extraits et s'est il passé
dans son image oui t'as vu comment je
parle
on rigole de tout ce que vous aussi vous
aussi dit prenez votre courage à deux
mains et je parle bien de courage je
m'adressais bernard montiel non moi je
vais vous dire franchement c'est
l'humour potache de cette émission c'est
le principe même de cette émission
ruquet est extrêmement brillant
intelligent c'est vrai que là c'est un
peu difficile tout ce qu'ils ont dit moi
je trouvais un peu dur c'est vrai de
dire que sur la tombe de jonnhy parce
qu'effectivement laetitia a dit qu'elle
a présentée à johnny jalil lespert
devant sa tombe et c'est parce que
laetitia elle y croit elle croit aux
étoiles au destin des choses comme ça
bon on m'a dit que violente a également
signé avec elle
comme elle pour finir sur le sujet on a
vu beaucoup de plans de coupe il ya non
seulement de laëtitia mais il y avait
déjà dit juste à côté
pour appelons là on n'a pas vu à la télé
il ya les brigitte mâcon qui étaient là
aussi qui s'est déplacé pour le concert
y trouve même n'ai pas dit ça commence
ils avaient précédement merci beaucoup
c'est un montant de